pourquoi on fait de la fumée avec la
bouche quand il fait froid ce n'est pas
de la fumée qui sort de la bouche mais
un petit nuage qui comme les gros dessus
de nos têtes est constitué de notre
corps est composé aux deux tiers d'eau
que nous renouvelons en permanence nous
éliminons en transpirant en urinant est
aussi sous forme de vapeur dans l'air
que nos ex pire quand il fait froid elle
passe soudain de la température de notre
corps environ 37 degrés à une
température extérieure bien plus basses
l'eau qui se présentait sous la forme de
vapeur autrement dit sous forme de gaz
se condense elle change d'état et
devient liquide ce sont ces toutes
petites gouttelettes en suspension dans
l'air extérieur qui forment cette espèce
de petit nuage devant la bouche
le même phénomène se produit quand on
souffle sur une vitre froide de la
vapeur d'eau s'y dépose est ce qu'on
danse